JAKE: We've been taking your
questions during the summit
and before and we're going to
put them to these guys here.
And these people are Linus
Upson, VP for Chrome;
Hiroshi Lockheimer,
the VP for Android;
Arnaud Weber, the engineering
director for Chrome Desktop
and Mobile; Darin Fisher, Chrome
Platform engineering lead;
Ian Ellison-Taylor, director of
product management on the web
platform; and Erik Kay,
director of software engineering
on Chrome Apps Extensions
and Native Client.
And I'm Jake, just Jake.
I like a small child
at New Year who's
been allowed to stay
until midnight with all
of the adults.
It's great.
So we're going to go through
the questions as well.
But if you have related
questions or comments
or you feel like someone hasn't
answered the question properly,
then please tweet about it.
Use the hashtag, which
is Chrome Dev summit,
or tweet directly at
Chrome Dev summit.
And the internet's Paul Irish
is going to be monitoring that.
And he's going to be using
his internet powers to direct
those questions onto the
screen, and I'll read them out.
So OK, let's get started
with the first question.
So developers can build for
the web for WebViews on Native.
How should developers
decide which to use?
Do you want to
kick us off, Linus?
LINUS UPSON: I'll
take a stab at it.
I think ultimately
it depends on what
you're trying to accomplish.
And so it's all about picking
the right tool for the job.
For many applications, you
want to write a native app
on a mobile device.
For many other
applications, you want
something that exists on the
web just a link away in a web
browser.
Other times, you want
to be able to share
code across different platforms,
both the web end on mobile,
and so you want to be
able to use WebView
for doing development.
But what we're trying
to do is just give you
the best of all
possible tools to get
done what you want to get done.
HIROSHI LOCKHEIMER:
Just to add to that,
we noticed in the Play
store that a lot of apps
actually use WebView.
A huge number actually of
apps, a big proportion of apps,
already use WebView.
So it may also not be
an either/or choice.
Like, some apps
do both in the app
depending on what the screen is
and what you're trying to do.
So a hybrid approach,
I think, is good, too.
I agreed completely with Linus.
JAKE: So if we were
building something
like a website for a shop, what
kind of properties of the app
or product would
you use to decide
which to use, like
WebView native?
What kind of properties?
LINUS UPSON: Well, I think
some of the obvious ones
are if you're
building a 3D game,
you're probably going to be
building on native for mobile.
If you're going to be
building something that's
very text intensive
and layout intensive,
the web is probably
a much better tool
for solving that job.
So it really depends.
I mean, there's thousands
of different kinds of apps,
and there's hundreds of
different dev stacks out there,
and you just need to pick
the right one for the job.
JAKE: I mean, we're getting 3D
on the web now as well, right?
We've got WebGL.
Are we seeing the web
as being something
that's going to grow and
take away from native?
Or is there always going to
be a use case for native?
Or is the web trying to go
to take over from native
or is it a different use case?
LINUS UPSON: It depends.
We saw this play out on
desktops and laptops before.
It's not as if native apps went
away when the web came about.
But the web enabled a
whole new set of use cases
that you couldn't do inside
of native applications.
The guys who started
Google Maps originally
were building a Windows app.
And then they figured out,
hey, we can do this on the web.
And because of the
lack of friction
on the web where you can get
to anything by just typing
in a URL or clicking
on a link, you
had many more people
could use maps easily
because they didn't have
to download and install
an application.
And so depending on what
you're trying to do--
and I think another
example I heard recently
was Ticketmaster.
So they actually spent
a lot of time and effort
and built this really
great mobile app.
But most people don't
buy tickets every day.
They buy them like
couple times a year.
And so that's a use
case where they probably
really want to be on the web.
And our job, as
the Chrome team, is
to make it so they can
deliver an experience as
rich and immersive as
you'd get in a native app,
but not force the
user to install
an application that
they're only going
to use once or twice a year.
JAKE: So one of
the other questions
we had is some developers choose
to build native apps rather
than for the web
because of performance.
What are we doing
to address that?
And so this
performance difference
that we see between
Chrome and native apps,
is that a fundamental
problem with the web?
Or is this something
that we can fix?
LINUS UPSON: Why
don't we ask Darin
since he's responsible
for fixing it.
[LAUGHTER]
IAN ELLISON-TAYLOR:
It's all Darin's fault.
DARIN FISHER: There you go.
Yeah, absolutely.
I mean, performance is one
of our biggest focuses,
and it seems like the
area of great opportunity.
This web-rendering
engine was designed
in the era of desktop computing
and bringing it to mobile's
been a challenge.
But it's one where there's
lots and lots of opportunity
to make the system
work a lot better.
It's actually very interesting.
If you think about
the web, web platform
is this retained model where
you describe your scene,
and if you describe
it in the right way,
the browser can actually
do a really good job
of rendering it.
The problem is there's just
a lot of ways in which you
can describe things incorrectly
and end up in a situation maybe
you might get a
pretty rendering,
but you don't actually
get a rendering
where it animates well.
And so there's a lot
of challenges for us
to not only make it
faster, but help developers
find that fast path and
stay on that fast path.
We're looking at
all these things.
It's both changes
that have to be
done in the system,
performance tuning,
and tooling that is
available to developers.
ERIK KAY: There is
also the security model
of dangerous APIs.
And when you talk about some
of the powerful capabilities
that you have with
native-installed applications,
today we don't have
a security model
on the web that
supports those APIs.
And that's why we have installed
packaged apps for Chrome OS,
and why we have native
apps on Android,
and that we have a security
model that now supports
the user choosing
to get this thing.
So until we solve that
problem, that divide
is going to continue
to exist as well.
JAKE: I mean, we can see
native apps doing things
like animation and paint work,
and it seems really fluid.
So what is it about the web
that seems to make this slower?
DARIN FISHER: There's
lots of historical things
that have been
challenging, right?
And lots of areas where
you can see the engines
have gotten faster and better at
handling those sorts of things.
For example, people
are familiar with using
CSS transforms to break
up their application
into various layers, where
each layer can be retained
by the engine, and then you
can perform an animation.
And the engine is smart
enough to move that layer
without forcing a repaint.
Even if you're writing a
native application on Android,
you're still very much thinking
about how do I avoid repaints?
How do I carefully
carve out my application
so that the various GP
resources can be used
and don't have to be recreated
and all that sort of thing?
It's actually very
similar in the web,
except sometimes it's
harder for developers
to actually see where
the memory is going,
how the layers are
set up, and so on.
So it's definitely
a challenge for us
to make sure that that's more
transparent to developers
and help them stay
on the fast path.
HIROSHI LOCKHEIMER:
Just to add to that,
it's also really easy to write
a really poorly performing app
natively as well.
So just because you write
a native app doesn't mean
you're automatically going
to get good performance.
You have to have
that in your mind
as you're developing your app.
Even at the OS level--
in the last year,
I think it was, we launched
Jelly Bean with Project Butter,
many of you may
have heard of that.
Bu that was a concerted
effort on our part
to make the operating system
really smooth and buttery.
And that took a lot of work.
And it's the same
at the app level,
at the native level,
as well as web apps.
JAKE: So we saw Paul Irish
before showing the layers
panel, right?
So we're starting to get these
tools to show developers,
so what's actually happening
under the hood, which
layers are being created.
What else are we doing?
I mean, we see on
native, like we
get these really fast-scrolling
lists by reusing memory
for things that
disappear offscreen.
Are we going to get something
like that on the web?
IAN ELLISON-TAYLOR:
Sure, I mean,
I think the so-called infinite
list problem is certainly
a challenge, where you
want to basically keep
creating new content as you
scroll through a view port.
That's an area we've
been actively focused on.
As we explore that, we see
a lot of low hanging fruit.
The render spends too
much time on x, y, and z,
and we can eliminate
that CPU cost
to help reduce the
cost of painting.
But also we can add
new primitives to CSS,
and we've talked
a lot about ways
to help developers
carve up the DOM so
that the costs are more limited.
But these are areas
of active exploration,
and it's not really clear
exactly what the solution will
be, but we want to make this
very easy because it seems
like it's a very common pattern.
JAKE: Is there
anything in particular
that, if people trying to
make a performant web app,
is this something
they should avoid
doing because of
the performance?
IAN ELLISON-TAYLOR:
Avoid repaints.
I think there was a
jankfree.org and a dejanking
talk by Nat and Tom.
I'm sure they talked
a lot about this.
JAKE: OK, so moving on
to the next question.
Are there plans for bringing
Chrome-based apps to Android
as an alternative
to native apps?
I guess this one's
for you, Eric.
ERIK KAY: Well, yes, we
have a solution for that,
and we talked about it a
little bit before, which
is using WebView
and through Cordova.
So we've been contributing
to the Cordova project
for the last year
and a half and really
trying to make it a better
experience for Android and iOS.
And part of that
process has involved
making it more modular, making
it easier to have plug-ins.
And one of the sets
of plug-ins that we're
going to be providing
is a set of modules
that allow you to
bring all the Chrome
apps, APIs, to
your Cordova apps.
So we have a bunch of
examples, actually, up
on our GitHub repo that sort
of show the same code that you
would just repackage
through Cordova
and have it running both on your
desktop and on iOS and Android.
JAKE: So that's packaging it
up using a separate program
and that will turn it into
an Android native app?
Is there any desire for
Android to natively support
the Chrome web apps?
ERIK KAY: Well, I
mean, to my mind,
it is natively
supporting it, right?
That basically,
the Play store is
where you get apps
for Android, right?
So it's not like we
want people to have
to know to go, oh, I go
here for some of my apps,
and this other place
for the rest of my apps.
Having them all be in the Play
store makes a lot of sense.
And for the developer,
packaging this up, like I said,
it literally is the
same source code.
So from their standpoint,
the difference
is just what is the end
package that's produced
and where do they upload it to.
Now, I think that we've been
investigating more ways that we
can coordinate the developer
experience between Play
and the Chrome Web
Store, and maybe
have shared developer consoles,
and that sort of thing.
We don't have anything to
announce on that front,
but we continue to look to
reduce developer friction.
JAKE: Yes, as you say, we've
got the Chrome Web Store
and the Play store.
Is this a confusing model,
having both of them?
Is there any plans
to unify the two?
ERIK KAY: So there's no plans
right now to unify the two.
I think for Chrome,
there's a place
where you go to get your
Chrome stuff, your themes,
your extensions, your apps.
For Android, there's a place
to get your phone and tablet
stuff.
I think to some
degree, we've looked
into what it would
look like if we tried
to merge some of these
things, and it winds up
being a little bit confusing.
You have to add
multiple hierarchies
of which device I looking
for and which stuff do I get?
We might figure something
out in the limit,
but I think from
a user standpoint,
we want to make
sure that if users
go to one store or
the other, and they're
looking for something else, that
we can give them the pointers
back, just so they find
things in the right place.
LINUS UPSON: Yeah,
but I think that's one
of things we've seen right now.
We don't end up with Android
users in the Chrome Web
Store going, where's my
Android apps or vice versa.
So I don't think it's
an issue for users.
JAKE: So we've been hearing
about the new Chrome-based
Android WebView in
some of the sessions
in the past couple of days.
It doesn't autoupdate.
That's correct, right?
Are there plans?
Is that underway?
ARNAUD WEBER: So
yes, autoupdate has
been one of the major features
of Chrome over the years,
and definitely it's
something that we
want to do for WebView as well.
We are facing some
significant challenges.
And we don't have
a date to announce,
but we are actively working on.
LINUS UPSON: Yeah, we
have a process in Chrome
with the various
prerelease channels,
plus a bunch of internal
testing and things
like that to make sure that
if we break someone's website,
we find out before
we go push it out
to hundreds of
millions of users.
I think one of the
challenges we have
with autoupdating
WebView is there's
this whole ecosystem of
Android apps that use WebView.
And If we're going to be
updating that thing very
rapidly, we need
to have mechanisms
to be able to test all
of those applications
and get feedback early in
the development process
to make sure we don't go
break a whole bunch of them
when we push out updates.
JAKE: But this is not a
problem on the web, right?
I mean, we update the
browser all the time,
and other browsers
update all the time.
LINUS UPSON: Oh, and we've
got massive automated testing
infrastructure to see what
we break and stuff like that.
During the development process,
before it actually gets out
to users, and also with
these early release channels,
like the Canary and Dev
Channel and Beta channel,
people can come and yell
and say, hey, file a bug.
You broke my website,
you bastards.
And we can fix it
before we go send it out
to a whole bunch of users.
And we don't have those
mechanisms, and processes,
and infrastructure
in place for testing
against the whole ecosystem
of Android apps yet.
And so that's one of the
big engineering challenges
we face and process
challenges we
face in being able to do that
because we want to get there,
but we figured out
all the problems yet.
ARNAUD WEBER: And so how
do we distribute something
that big across all
the devices of the OEMs
or the networks that occurs?
JAKE: So it seems like getting
the Chrome WebView on that
was kind of was a
big challenge, right?
Because it's been
the old Android
browser for a long time now.
We got Chrome as
the default browser,
but we still had
the old WebView.
What were the challenges there?
What were the real problems?
And why do we see
the Chrome WebView
having a kind of slightly
different feature set
to the Chrome browser?
ARNAUD WEBER: Basically, it
was another part of Chrome
to do something different.
It's a single-process
environment.
It's a slightly different
graphic architecture.
There are very
small differences,
by the way, which
are WebGL, WebRTC,
and the hardware
part for Canvas 2D.
And by the way, we're
working actively
to fix those and make them just
like Chrome moving forward.
JAKE: So because it's a
single-process model compared
to Chrome, how does
that affect performance?
Is there is a performance
difference there?
ARNAUD WEBER: The
only difference
I'm aware of is Canvas 2D, which
is using a software path so
far.
Other than that,
the architecture
is actually simpler than
what we have in Chrome.
So it's not a problem.
JAKE: So you can put WebView
into a hardware-accelerated
mode or leave it
in a software mode.
ARNAUD WEBER: Absolutely, yes.
JAKE: Why would people do that?
Why are so many people
using a software mode
on the old WebView?
ARNAUD WEBER: Darin?
DARIN FISHER: I
mean, it's simply
because they want
to read back-- often
because they want to read back
the bit map or the rendering,
and they want to do their
own processing with that.
If you're in that
situation where
your goal of using the
WebView is to get the pixels,
then perhaps software
rendering is better for you.
Because if there's
a hardware readback,
it's going to be slow.
JAKE: I've seen that before,
because I had a Canvas
demo that I wrote a
number of years ago,
which was analyzing the
pixels in every frame.
And it was running
at 60 frame-- well,
about 30 frames a
second a few years ago.
And then the switch went
right to hardware Canvas,
and all of a sudden, the
demo just completely died.
Is that part of the same thing?
DARIN FISHER: Yeah, sure.
Exactly.
So it has a lot to
do with the use case.
If it's a WebView usage,
where it's all about display,
then the GPU path is
going to be great.
And the other interesting
thing about the WebView
is just the way it's integrated.
It's integrated so that it
acts like an Android view.
And that definitely
affects the way it renders.
So it tries to
conform to that API.
At any rate, there's a
lot of other subtle--
there were a lot of other
challenges to getting
the Chrome code base to
provide a good Android WebView,
and a lot of it had to
do is compatibility.
The Android WebView was a very
established piece of code,
where a lot of
applications were depending
on a large volume of
Android applications
using it and using it in subtle
and interesting ways, ways
in which perhaps it wasn't
originally designed.
And yet we had to go
and discover those ways
and make sure they
were still supported.
It's all been very fascinating.
JAKE: So a slightly
different next question.
And I'm sorry if I sound
bored reading it out,
but I'm really,
really bored of it.
What is the current
stance, if any,
on moving responsive
image implementations
forward like Solset?
I feel that what's
going to happen
is that we're going to
reach the-- we will launch
the responsive image solution.
It will be standardized,
and then that's it.
We run out of numbers for years.
That's it.
The time has ended.
We've ran out of
time to do anything.
The universe will
implode on itself.
DARIN FISHER: Did you
read Blink-dev yesterday?
JAKE: No, I didn't.
DARIN FISHER:
Anyways, there's a lot
of active discussion
on this topic,
you know, source in,
source set, so on.
I think from Chrome's
point of view,
we'd love to find a
great solution here.
As people have been talking
about this more and more,
more refinement of the use
cases has sort of come out,
and people are again circling
on the right solutions.
It's really important to
us that we don't end up
with three different
ways of doing responsive
design in Chrome for images.
We would really like to
find one good solution that
addresses the majority
of the use cases
that all the browser vendors
can feel good about and adopt.
That would be a lot better
than us shipping all.
And we've been there before.
We have three different ways
of specifying CSS gradients,
or gradients in CSS,
and that's unfortunate.
And here, with
responsive images,
we want to also be
thoughtful and responsible
with the platform, and yet find
a darn solution because we know
that people are hungry for this.
JAKE: I kind of feel that maybe
the working group discussion
hasn't been completely
fruitful for this.
Could we do something
like get a few balls, one
for each of the responsive
image solutions,
put some cat food in, and
then just bring a cat in?
[LAUGHTER]
JAKE: Whichever ball the
cat goes to, we just do it.
DARIN FISHER: I like
the way you're thinking.
That's an interesting one.
Recently, there was the
source-end proposal,
and that's been shopped around.
And there's been interesting
feedback from the WebKit folk,
and that's going
into the-- people
are now taking that
into consideration.
Then picture sort
of came up again.
It's, hey, maybe that will
solve all our problems.
And then Hicksey's
like, well, but you guys
realize mulitelement solutions
are really painful for x,
y and z, and blah, blah, blah.
And the whole thing
circles around.
But I do feel like there's
a lot of motivation
to solve this problem.
JAKE: So developing
web apps is becoming
more and more complex
and low level.
What steps are you taking to
keep web development high level
without making me,
as a developer,
have to delve into paint
operations and GPU cycles.
And I love this question
because it's so loaded.
[LAUGHTER]
IAN ELLISON-TAYLOR: I can
talk a little bit about that.
I think we've kind of
talked a lot about that
the last day or so.
I mean, because we level
that low-level stuff as well.
We're kind of going
in both directions,
giving you more
low-level features
if you really want to
get closer to the metal.
And that's the whole
sort of-- WebJail
being the classic example.
But then we're doing these
higher level things as well.
We've been working obviously
on features like Flexbooks
and Grid, and then coming up
to Web Components, and now
Polymer.
So we're trying
to kind of come in
without having too many
layers, but to have
these different layers
that you can come in,
depending on your
particular scenario.
So you can get up and
running really quickly.
But you can still get access
to the low-level APIs,
if that's what you want to do.
And you can start one layer
and work your way down.
So we're kind of coming at
it from different angles.
DARIN FISHER: Yeah, exactly.
I feel like part of
the answer is let's
make the low level less
scary and more accessible,
better tools, that
sort of thing.
Because like or
not, you often do
you really need to
understand what's going on.
But then things like
Web Components gives us
the substrate for which
we can, and developers
can, and other people
can, provide components
that people can use that
hopefully solves the problems
so people don't have
to fight through them.
IAN ELLISON-TAYLOR:
That other people part
is also really important
because obviously we're
huge supporters of
own Polymer effort.
But the idea behind
Web Components
is that there can
be lots of providers
for lots of different use cases.
We're not going to
implement every widget known
to man or woman.
So there's going
to be lots of-- we
hope-- lots of
third-party support,
given Web Components
allows interoperability
between these
different frameworks.
So that's very cool.
We've not had that before.
LINUS UPSON: Yeah, and
I think, as an example,
Mozilla X-Tags can play
nicely with Polymer components
on the same page at same time.
IAN ELLISON-TAYLOR: Yeah,
many third-party vendors
have come out and
said yeah, they're
getting ready to build
their own Web Components
and frameworks that
can then interoperate.
DARIN FISHER: I mean,
not to beat it to death,
but the cool thing
about Web Components
is it's just like
custom HTML tags.
And all these
frameworks that already
have existed since forever, they
all work with HTML elements.
So they all work
with Web Components.
It's really cool if
you think about it.
You don't have to throw away
what you're already doing.
You can just sort
of gently embrace
parts of things done
as Web Components.
It's actually really neat.
JAKE: I think, there is
an idea in this question
that web development
should be high level.
I mean, I remember working in
places where you had developers
who just did solve HTML and CSS.
And then you had
sort of another set
of developers doing JavaScript.
And none of them
were really caring
about sort of the
low-level paint stuff.
Is that no longer a possibility?
Are we saying that
no, developers
need to maybe grow up?
Or are there other
different jobs?
LINUS UPSON: I
think that goes back
to one of the earlier
questions about why
are native apps
faster than the web?
Well, it turns
out in many cases,
you can get exactly the same
performance on both platforms,
if you know what you're doing.
And the problem is, like Darin
mentioned earlier, there's
many, many poorly lit paths
through the web platform,
where if you go
wandering off in there,
bad things are going
to happen to you.
And so doing things like
Web Components and Polymer
gives us the opportunity
to give developers
a high level, well-lit path
that's also highly performant,
because it stays on all the
fast paths inside of Blink
and inside of Chrome.
JAKE: Hiroshi, is there this
feeling in the native world
as well?
Because I know nothing about it.
Are there sections
of developers who
feel like that kind
of low-level thing
isn't something they
should be caring about?
Because you've got primitives
on Android as well,
but you can sort of do
extra things with them.
Other developers who
are saying, look,
I shouldn't have to be
caring about this stuff.
It should just do it.
HIROSHI LOCKHEIMER:
Yeah, and this
is similar to the point I was
trying to make earlier, which
is it's actually pretty easy to
write a poorly performing app
for native as well.
And as a native
developer, you have
to pay attention to
these same things.
And there are poorly lit alleys
in the native world as well.
And you just have to
be aware of this stuff.
And this was a big
part of what we
pushed last year with
Jelly Bean again.
With this big push on Project
Butter, we have new tools.
We had new tools that
we made available
so that people can
trace, the developers
can trace what
their app is doing
and figure out what
the bottlenecks are.
It's all, I think,
the same concepts.
It's just different
sets of technologies.
But it's really the same thing.
LINUS UPSON: I think
it's also that there's
cultural differences in the
developer communities as well.
I think, historically,
web developers
haven't cared about
60 Hertz animations.
It just hasn't been
on people's radar.
It's not something that you
just expect from a website.
But if you're a
mobile developer,
that's something that you've
expected from day one.
And so, you go, OK, you
start thinking about how do I
get 60 Hertz and then start
adding features on top of that.
Whereas many web projects,
they go add all their features,
and then go, holy cow,
how do I make this fast?
And so one of the things we
try to do inside of Google
with lots of other web
developers inside the company
is get them onto the
fast paths first.
Get their Hello World,
the very first thing
they going, on all
the right fast paths
and keep it fast
through development
as they add features
and capabilities
and round out what
their program does.
Because it's much, much
harder if someone's
been hacking on HTML, CSS,
and JavaScript for a year,
and then they turn up and
say, hey, I'm really slow,
and I use a lot of memory.
Can you help me?
It's much easier to start
fast and stay fast and have
automated tests to
make sure that you stay
on those fast path as you
keep adding things to it.
JAKE: And in terms of like
getting smooth web performance
from the web, and
developers not really--
this is something
we've been pushing
the past year that developers
have to care about this.
And it's been a new
thing to many developers.
Is that a culture
that we've created?
Not Chrome specifically,
but sort of browser
manufacturers, that it just
wasn't possible for so long
that the web was this fairly
high level, pretty slow thing
that developers couldn't
do anything about?
Have we created that culture
of just throw text on the page
and just hope it works?
DARIN FISHER: Well,
I-- look, I feel
like if you look back at
the way the web developed
and the innovation on
mobile that happened,
where people said, hey,
fixed position elements
don't have to suck because
they can get their own layers.
And overflow scroll can
actually get its own layer.
That sort of promotion of
things to their own layer
so that they can take advantage
of GPU acceleration and avoid
repaints, that sort of thing
is very novel and necessary
in the touch environment.
And it's something that wasn't
there with desktop rendering.
I mean, the old way
of rendering Chrome--
sorry, rendering web browsers
was rasterize the whole thing,
and if there's damage, we
reraster the damaged part.
And it didn't take
into account the fact
that there might be
separable layers and all
this sort of thing.
If scrolling happened,
we shifted the bits,
and we rasterized
the exposed region.
I mean, there was no
prerendering down the fold
so that you could
efficiently scroll.
These are all new
techniques, techniques
that are essential on
touchscreen, touch devices,
mobile devices, or
underpowered laptops.
You sort of see that's
where the industry is going.
A lot of users are on
these low-powered devices.
We've got to make the
web-rendering engine
work well there.
And it does mean
changing a lot of things.
We've had to make some
breaking changes the way
fixed position elements work.
Today, we've made them create
their own stacking context,
which was a spec-breaking
change necessary to allow
for better performance.
And for Chrome, it's
been this evolution
of getting more and more
of these mobile ideas,
these sort of-- have them
actually apply to desktop.
And we're getting there.
ERIK KAY: So to the
core of your question
about low level
versus high level,
the primitives versus
these high-level concepts,
one of the things
that we've seen
is that when people start
with high-level concepts,
and then they want
to change it in a way
that the high-level
construct didn't allow,
they start having to
hack their way around it.
And that's the
kind of thing that
winds up actually contributing
to some of the performance
issues.
And so if instead,
you say, well, it's
OK to have high-level
constructs.
But they're built up out of
primitives that we expose.
So if you want to recreate
that high-level thing
or pick and choose and
take bits and pieces of it,
you can do that.
And that's part of what we're
doing with Web Components,
is that even though it
hides things from you,
you can still drill
in and get into it
and take it apart and do
something different with it,
that you don't need necessarily
to start at the high level.
You could start at the low
level and build up from there.
JAKE: So yesterday, I was
ripping into application cache
for its manifest format,
where you add a line to it,
and you've set up routing and
caching sort of all at once.
And it's not always clear
that you've done all that,
or that one line
doesn't read like it
should do all of those things.
We have TranslateZ(0),
which as an API says,
I want you to move this
nowhere on the Z-index.
But that's promoting
something to a GPU layer.
Is that another example?
Is that one of those kind
of APIs that's kind of doing
something it shouldn't?
DARIN FISHER: Perhaps.
One of the things that we've
been really excited about
is trying to identify more
of the bedrock of the web
platform.
You can see the work that's
happening with service worker.
You're very familiar
with this, Jake.
All the stuff there that's
thinking about App Cache
v2 or App Cache Exploded
or finding the primitives
in App Cache and giving those
developers so that something
like App Cache can
be explained cleanly,
I think stuff like TranslateZ(0)
is kind of like this
as well, although
that one is a very
indirect way of
saying what you mean.
Really, fixed position elements
should just get promoted.
And ditto for overflow scroll
and so on and so forth.
But yeah, in general, we're
very interested in trying
to find-- to be careful of
these sort of high-level APIs
that trap you and limit,
actually, your flexibility.
High-level APIs can be
really great for giving you
guide rails, but you need
to be able to sometimes step
aside and find-- and
do things differently
than what the API
designers were thinking.
I mean, App Cache is just
the greatest example of this.
But there are plenty of other
examples in the platform.
So the more we
can put developers
in control, the better.
The more we can enable
developers to create frameworks
or Web Components that allow
other developers be more
successful, that just makes
everything go much better.
If everything is gated
on improvements to Blink,
we're not going to go very far.
JAKE: So I've had developers ask
for a specific API or CSS rule
or something for promoting
an element to a GPU layer.
But I suppose that
would be tying it
to a particular architecture.
DARIN FISHER: Well, there's
a real cost to that, right?
If a web page says, hey, I
need this to be a GP layer.
Well, what happens when
you don't have enough VRAM?
And so there's
definitely this challenge
of making sure that we don't
create a platform that we're
going to regret, too.
JAKE: Also, part of the reason
that we have this Translate 0
is that one day we could reverse
that and do something else,
do something faster
that isn't specifically
promoting to a GPU layer.
DARIN FISHER: Yeah, I
mean, it is just a promise
that it be rendered-- that it
appear a certain way, right?
If we don't have the memory
to do it, we can't do it.
JAKE: Cool.
Sorry, I really like
rendering performance.
It's part of my thing,
so I think I probably
let that question ride probably
longer than I should have.
ERIK KAY: By the way,
there's another example
like this, where the
problem is sometimes
that when you give developers
this thing that says--
that looks like,
make this go faster,
they will liberally sprinkle
that over their code.
And the problem is that
as a platform, that
limits what we can do
to optimize things.
So a classic example of
this is that some languages
with garbage
collectors in the past
had a way of invoking the
garbage collector, of you
saying, do it now.
And the problem is that that
often is like the worst thing
to do.
The garbage collectors
can be very fast
if they can look at the patterns
that decide when to do things
and how to migrate stuff
from old space to new space
and-- or new space to old
space, rather, and all that.
And if the developer
is constantly saying,
no, no, GC now, GC now, you're
actually slowing things down,
not speeding things up.
So sometimes hiding some of
these implementation details,
there's actually
some benefit to it.
HIROSHI LOCKHEIMER:
This conversation
is really fascinating to me
as the native Android guy,
because it's exactly
the same stuff that
happens in the
native world, right?
So it's fascinating.
One thing I think--
I'm surprised no one
mentioned it, the Blink tag.
I think that's what
caused the problem, right?
Because it's one frame a second.
I mean, come on.
JAKE: Nothing to do with the
Blink rendering engine, right?
Yeah, yeah, we're not
responsible for that.
[LAUGHTER]
JAKE: Who do we blame for this?
Was it Microsoft?
Or Netscape?
Someone else, right?
Not us.
So Android has this
codified design guidelines
for application design, right?
Are there any plans to release
dedicated UI guidelines
for Chrome apps or
extension development?
ERIK KAY: So Polymer is probably
where you're going to see this.
So Polymer's really our
bet for sort of saying,
not only are we going to
provide components that
are going to be really easy
to use and really powerful
and really performant,
but they're
going to have a nice
opinionated look and feel.
And we're going to
set animation curves,
and we're going to set
spacing, and font selection,
and whatever.
Now, again, because it's the
web, you can ignore all that
and do whatever you want.
But the whole point is to
make the easy things easy.
We want to have
that well-lit path.
We want to guide you toward
something where if you just
want to make something that
looks nice that you can,
and you can do it easily.
IAN ELLISON-TAYLOR: I
think the bottom line
is we want the default
to just be beautiful
and just to have something
that you'd be proud of just
for no effort.
And then second layer
being that, well, now you
want to maybe do some
easy customization.
You don't have to rewrite
everything, just the normal CSS
that you know and
love today will work.
And then there's the layer
below that says, OK, now I
want something
really custom, so I'm
going to use the
lower-level primitives.
I'm going to use animation.
I'm going to use something lower
level to really customize it.
But you don't have to
rewrite everything.
It'll all just hang together.
LINUS UPSON: Yeah, we've
had this discussion
inside the team for years,
where the web is kind
of like-- design on the web
is kind of like evolution
in the tropics.
I mean, it's where really
crazy organisms evolve.
And many of them are pretty
hideous, but some of them
are really spectacular.
Because there's no
guiding UI toolkit
for the web from
the very beginning.
And I think that's very
different than most
other platforms, where there
is a standard system toolkit,
and when you use that, you
get all the apps sort of have
a very similar look and
feel and stuff like that.
But usually, very often,
the most popular apps
on each platform will then
step outside the toolkit
because they want to do some new
and innovative thing on the UI.
And so we see these
things coming at it
from opposite directions.
But with Polymer, we'd
really like at least there
to be a widely deployed
option on the web
where you can have more similar
and more standardized look
and feel.
JAKE: If I download an
app for Android or iPhone
and I see that they've
decided, oh no, the button
should go at the bottom
and they should be purple.
Really?
They've changed the--
they're different
now from of other apps.
And this to me, it
looks like a bad thing.
But that's not true
on the web, right?
There's so much
innovation in UI design.
If we brought the web to have
a more standardized feel,
would the web be
losing something.
Or would it make
it easier to use?
LINUS UPSON: Well, I think both.
And what will happen on the
web is some people will use it,
and you'll start to see more
commonality between sites,
where people aren't
putting in a lot of effort.
But usually most of
the popular places
are going to heavily customize.
And I think you'll see the same
thing in native and on the web.
But on the web, they
just haven't even
had a standard toolkit to choose
from, so it's just impossible.
So we at least want
to give that option.
JAKE: So how do we deal
with user expectations,
with regard to offline web apps?
So if we fix this thing
with service worker,
you could say in some
way in some cases,
you can fix it with
application cache,
there's no user
expectation there.
No one opens a browser when
they've got no connection
and expects it to work.
What can we do to fix that?
ERIK KAY: Well, there's a couple
ways to think about offline.
So whenever people typically--
when they say offline,
they tend to think,
oh, I'm on an airplane.
I'm somewhere far
away from a network.
I have no network.
The most common offline
use case is actually
the use case where my
network is just bad.
Or it's mostly good and
just occasionally bad.
Or there's a hotel proxy
that got in the way.
Or something bad happened that
would cause an interruption.
And technologies
like service worker,
and even Application
Cache in some cases,
can smooth those
bumps out and make it
so that you don't notice.
And that's, I think,
a key innovation
for the web, regardless
of the entry point.
Now, that said, when you
are offline, really offline,
I agree this is a big problem
that web browsers don't
address well today.
And it's actually
one of the reasons
why we did packaged
apps, is because we--
and did them the way we
did, is we pulled them
outside the browser, give
you a surface on the desktop,
like a Native app, to remove
some of those barriers.
Because if you think about
it, it's not just the--
there's a couple barriers
you have to get through.
One is the psychological
thing of well,
should I even
launch this browser?
I know I don't have a network.
And everything's
going to be broken,
and all my restored tabs
are going to be busted.
So why would you even
do that to begin with?
And if you decided
you were going
to do that, then how do
you navigate to your thing?
Well, did you memorize that URL?
Did you bookmark it?
For many people,
they search for it.
They use a search
engine and guess what?
If you're offline, you
can't search for it.
And so even just navigating
the normal use case
where you navigate
to your offline
enabled app is now broken.
And so that's part of some
of the motivation with what
we did with packaged apps.
That said, I do think that
this is a problem we can solve
and-- or improve, I should say.
Probably not solve,
because it's unlikely
that we'll ever get a
significant portion of the web
really offline enabled.
Think Wikipedia
or Google search.
These are things which
fundamentally are just
not going to cache
themselves completely offline
and not going to be--
LINUS UPSON: Well, the problem
is even with native apps now,
most everything-- all
the popular things people
do require a network connection.
I mean, sure, I can
go look at old tweets
when I'm offline, but--
JAKE: But if they update in the
background, they're not old.
LINUS UPSON: Ah, now you've
got a power question.
If I have 100 apps doing
that, I've got a problem.
JAKE: So did we find-- did
offline work in the Chrome app
space?
Did users actually expect it
to work with out a connection?
ERIK KAY: Yeah, I mean,
it does mostly work.
Now again, the trick
about it is, again, it's
not necessarily about
does it function?
Does it have all the features
that the app would have?
It's more about does
it not break, right?
And does it recover gracefully?
When you launch Skype and
you don't have a network
connection, you don't expect
to be able to do a video chat,
right?
LINUS UPSON: But you wouldn't
expect a white rectangle
that says 404 something.
ERIK KAY: Yeah, exactly.
And you expect that, oh,
if the network reconnects
that it will suddenly
wake up and start to work.
You didn't have to find a
reload button, a refresh,
or quit the app and
restart it, right?
And that's kind of
thing that, yes,
it is working quite
well with packaged apps.
LINUS UPSON: Yeah, but I think
the key to what Eric said is,
so we've done tons
of user studies.
We have lots of
customers who are
using various
Google apps offline.
The big thing is
they need an access
point outside the browser.
And when they click it,
they can't launch a browser
because the browser is
just full of land mines
when you're offline.
There's hardly
anything you can touch
that will work when
you're offline.
And so having it be
in its own window
and having a dedicated
access point to it
are the key things for
doing genuinely offline type
applications.
JAKE: Yeah, you're right.
If I open Skype or whatever,
and it was just a blank window,
I would consider that to
be a broken experience.
If I had no connection,
if I open a browser
and I've got no connection,
I type in the URL,
and it says-- it
does that, it dials,
and, like, yeah, I've
got no connection.
The difference between
the two is an icon
in the space where
I would expect
to find apps on that platform.
ERIK KAY: It's not just that.
As Linus was saying, it's the
affordances in the browser.
It's the address bar and
bookmarks and all the land
mines.
LINUS UPSON: The back button,
closing tabs, and the menu.
JAKE: I mean, in Chrome
apps, there is a URL buy.
If I install TweetDeck, it
can open as a tab, right?
If a Chrome URL?
ERIK KAY: So that's a
difference between what
are-- what we did in V1,
which was hosted apps, which
were really just web pages
with some additional built-in
permissions to it.
With packaged apps,
there's no URL bar.
It's completely
outside the browser
and stand-alone windows.
JAKE: So Blink established
some guidelines
for how new features
should be introduced.
I like covering that, the
compatibility risks and things
like that, what other
browsers are saying.
And lately, there's
been some discussion
around the possibility of the
Dart VM going into Chrome.
What's the plan there?
Who's brave?
LINUS UPSON: Sure.
So one the things
we set out to do
from the beginning with both
Native Client and Dart was we
wanted people to
be able to write
code that would run
in all browsers.
So we wanted to be able
to have a path, where
we can compile C code
down to JavaScript
and run it in all
browsers, including Chrome.
We want people to be
able to write Dart code
and run in all browsers
by compiling it down
to JavaScript.
And so the capability
of being able to work
in these other languages
is useful to a number
of developers.
And so we wanted to enable that.
That was sort of
the baseline for it.
But then going
beyond that, you say,
is JavaScript really the
best VM to execute C code in?
I mean, it's possible.
But are you going to get the
best possible performance
by doing that?
And will you be
able to do things
like threads and other things?
Similar questions
come up with Dart.
We can compile Dart
down to JavaScript,
but that might
not be the fastest
way you can run the language.
And so the Dart team basically
took on a challenge that said,
we're not even going to
think about putting the Dart
VM into Chrome unless we can
show dramatic performance
enhancement, both in
terms of startup time
and in terms of
execution performance.
And so that's what they're
working on right now.
And also we want to
do it in a way that
doesn't add a tremendous
amount of complexity to Blink
and the rest of
the web platform.
It needs to be done
in a way that's
essentially orthogonal
to everything else that's
going on.
Because we can't just
keep bolting in new VMs
left and right if
we end up with some
horrible in square
dependency mesh.
So that's the way we're
looking at the problem.
We haven't made any
explicit decisions yet
about what we're going to do.
But that's how we're
thinking about it
JAKE: So my knowledge of
Pinnacle is actually quite low,
but I mean, I get
the feeling this
is for-- I can write
in whatever language
I'm most comfortable
with and compile it
down to something Pinnacle
can run really, really fast.
Is that something that
could happen with Dart?
I mean, would we need to
put the Dart VM into Chrome?
Or would we just be able to take
to compile it using something
like Pinnacle?
Is that one solution that
would cover both cases?
ERIK KAY: Well, I
mean, the Dart2js
is already actually
doing this quite well.
If you look at some of the
benchmarks they're doing,
and some of the tree shaking
and other our whole program
optimizations that they're
able to do with Dart2js,
they can make programs
that take a Dart
and make it a Dart
programming and emit
JS that's much faster than
handwritten equivalent to JS
is.
So in some ways, they
are there more there
but they're moving that way.
Really, Pinnacle
is-- it certainly
could be used for
that, and it's possible
that we could get
comparable performance.
Honestly, though, if they can
get-- do it with JavaScript,
it's--
LINUS UPSON: Basically,
with Pinnacle,
the security and
platform portability
that you get with
Pinnacle would just
make implementing a
VM like a modern VM,
a modern Java VM, JavaScript
VM, Dart VM in Pinnacle.
It just would not be as
fast in that environment
as if you implement it natively.
JAKE: Hm.
That makes sense.
DARIN FISHER: And so there's
another interesting thing,
which is just that
one of Dart's goals
is to interact with the
DOM and to be very much
an alternative to
JavaScript, right?
Whereas with Pinnacle, it's
a plug-in architecture.
It's very much
asynchronous to what's
going on on the main
thread, where the DOM lives.
And so it's just very different.
You wouldn't be able to
actually take the Dart VM
and run it in that
plug-in context
and have synchronous
direct access to the DOM.
And so it's just a
different environment.
JAKE: So Pinnacle does not
have direct access to the DOM.
It's like a sandbox.
DARIN FISHER: It runs is
asynchronously to everything
for performance.
JAKE: Is there any kind of
equivalent sort of postMessage
for it to sort of get out into--
DARIN FISHER: Yes,
there's a postMessage API.
JAKE: I'm basically just
asking questions because
of my own ignorance
about this stuff now.
I should get back to actually
questions people asked.
And it does turn
out that this one
is about Native
Client, which is great.
IAN ELLISON-TAYLOR: Or maybe go
to the Pinnacle session, maybe
watch the online stream, though.
JAKE: Yeah, there's
a problem there.
Between all of the
sessions, I was
busy writing the intro
for the next session.
So I'm assuming this
was a good summit.
But I don't really know, right?
IAN ELLISON-TAYLOR: We'll
look at the feedback later.
JAKE: Well, it's
all recorded, right?
So I can actually just--
I'm off next week,
so I'll just do that.
My girlfriend would
actually hate that if I just
spent the whole thing
watching DEV videos.
I'm actually banned from
using a laptop next week.
Any plans for supporting Native
Client in Chrome on Android?
Because it's not there
at the moment, right?
ERIK KAY:Yeah, we don't
have any plans right now.
To be honest, we've been
focused on the desktop
and making that experience
as good as we can.
And I think right
now Android does
have a great solution for
delivering native code on it
already.
So it didn't have the
same needs that we
had in the web of
filling in the gap.
In terms of in a
browser, Clank right now
is, I think, really focused
on being smaller, faster,
more efficient.
And so it has to try to get as
much as the web platform in it
as we can.
So again, we're taking
our time thinking
about things like this.
ARNAUD WEBER: And
Clank is [INAUDIBLE].
ERIK KAY: Sorry, yes.
I used a code name.
JAKE: Someone leaked it.
Isn't it like a fire?
You get fired if you leak a
code name for a project, right?
Is that, yeah?
[LAUGHTER]
JAKE: OK, so I
actually remember--
I'd gone out drinking
with few friends.
And this was in London, and
I was making my way back,
and this was like at midnight.
I was quite drunk.
I was on the Underground, and
I just got talking to someone.
I don't really speak to
people when I'm not drunk,
but this time I was.
IAN ELLISON-TAYLOR:
So right now you are.
JAKE: Yeah, yeah.
I've had a few whiskies
before I came here.
[LAUGHTER]
JAKE: I was just telling
you guys a story.
I thought we could
do with a break.
[LAUGHTER]
JAKE: But someone-- I
was talking to someone,
and they weren't working
in the web or anything.
And they said to me that
their boyfriend had told them
not to use Chrome
because of memory usage.
That was actually the
first time I'd heard that,
but I've seen it since.
Are we doing something to
decrease the memory usage
in Chrome?
And if you have
multiple tabs open,
this is especially a
case on mobile, right?
LINUS UPSON: Yeah, I
think the memory issues--
there's two things going on.
One, we always need to use
less memory than we're using.
I don't care how much we're
using, we need to use less.
And we have lots of
dashboards to track it
and continually working
to drive things down.
Two, though, because of Chrome's
multiprocess architecture,
there's a lot of misinformed
reporting about how much
memory Chrome actually uses.
Because there's a lot of shared
memory between those processes.
And so if you really want
to measure the memory
usage of a complex system, the
gold standard way of doing it--
and there's a page
on Chromium.org--
I can't remember exactly where
it is-- that describes how
to do this, which
is basically you
get a system you have to
completely quiesce it.
You look at how many pages
of RAM are actually in use.
And then you run
your experiment,
and you ask the
operating system, OK,
how many pages of RAM
are actually in use now?
Because some of the
memory that's allocated by
the browser is actually
held in kernel space.
Some of it's shared
between multiple processes,
so you've got to make sure
you count it exactly once.
And so you basically
have to look
at it from the whole
operating system layer
and find out during your test,
what was the beginning memory
usage and what was
the end memory usage?
And see what that is.
So the first thing
I get frustrated,
because people keep
sending these blog
articles about Chrome's
using 10 gigs of RAM.
It's like, no, it's not.
And well, some people have
a lot of tabs open but--
[LAUGHTER]
LINUS UPSON: --the
other thing we found out
is as we make Chrome faster
and make it use less memory,
which we have over the
years, people open more tabs,
and web applications use more
RAM, which is another problem.
But anyway, we recently
had a big project
to reduce memory usage,
particularly on mobile.
And it had a lot of benefits
on other platforms as well.
ARNAUD WEBER: So yeah,
it's in Chromium 31.
And it's really part
of the [INAUDIBLE],
which the main focus was to run
great on 512 megabyte devices.
And so Chrome-- we had a
very large folder on this,
and we reduced
memory significantly.
DARIN FISHER: And we have
a pretty ambitious project
going on involving improving the
garbage collection of basically
DOM object wrappers.
Basically, today the DOM
is reference counted,
and JavaScript is
garbage collected,
and they can-- the
garbage collector
can get-- it can take it a
while to learn that there's
a whole bunch of garbage
that's outside of the garbage--
outside of the VAT that it can
actually release references to.
This is the Oilpan
project that you
might have heard
of on Blink-dev.
And we're very excited
about opportunities
there to improve-- keep the
steady state memory usage down
of applications that do a lot
of DOM traversals, or whatnot.
ERIK KAY: There's
a related problem,
too, that Linus
kind of alluded to,
which is that oftentimes
memory usage is really
the web pages using
a lot of memory.
The web pages are doing
more advanced things.
They're now growing.
And I think one of
our responsibilities
is improving the developer tools
so that developers can diagnose
these problems more easily.
And we've been adding a bunch
of things to Chrome Dev tools
to help users-- developers
find memory leaks
and to identify large growth
and to fix those problems.
LINUS UPSON: Yeah, and I think
the other thing is users,
I don't think, should have
to be responsible for memory
management.
If I want to open 100 tabs,
why can't I open 100 tabs?
I think the browser can get
a lot smarter about evicting
things from memory
that aren't being used.
It's difficult to do as an app
on a PC, on Windows or Mac,
because you don't know what
else is going on in the system.
And you don't want to
necessarily be throwing away
memory just because there's some
other app, like they launched
Photoshop, and it
flushes all of your tabs.
But on platforms like
Android and Chrome OS,
where we have a more
holistic view about what's
going on in the
system, we can be
smarter about managing
the total memory usage
and consumption of the browser.
JAKE: Yeah, I get
myself into a state
sometimes where the tabs get so
small that the icon disappears.
And that's when I
have to really think
about where my life's heading.
In fact, sometimes I
don't have Chrome open,
and I'm about to open it,
because I've restarted
the machine or whatever, I
look over at my router at home
and it just like, puppy dog
eyes, and it shakes its head,
and it's like tell you what?
I'll disable Wi-Fi, then
open Chrome, and then
turn Wi-Fi back on and
just go to the tab I need.
[LAUGHTER]
JAKE: So--
LINUS UPSON: You need help.
JAKE: Yeah, I know.
So packaged apps
is one mechanism
to adding richer APIs
for WebView apps.
You know, we're doing that
sourcing with Cordova PhoneGap.
We also packaged
apps just on desktop.
So we've got this
at home screen thing
as well that just puts an
icon on the home screen,
but it doesn't really
give it anything else.
It doesn't give any new APIs.
Is there a future
where we could do
that, like have the
actual installation
step that grants extra APIs?
ARNAUD WEBER: So let me talk
about that a little bit.
Actually, so, it's in the
N31 beta and [? N32 ?] beta,
and hopefully it's going
to be on [? N32 ?] stable.
There is a new meta tag you can
use in fact, as a developer,
to prompt the user
to say hey, do you
want to install this
on your home screen?
So in a way, there's a
way to do that today.
IAN ELLISON-TAYLOR: The idea
of giving enhanced permissions
to an application
that's installed
this way, one of our goals is
to try to-- one of the really
cool things about the web is
it that you can just get up
and using that application
very quickly, and then
only sort of bother
the user with prompts
when they actually want to
get access to some capability.
And so we're excited about, as
we've been doing for a while,
adding more
capabilities to the web.
And I think that whole
home screen thing
is an important part of
giving web apps that presence
on the launch surface
that the user is going
to when they think
about launching an app.
The permissions problem
doesn't necessarily
have to be coupled to
the way in which you
launch an application.
LINUS UPSON: I think
the core challenge
that we face is really squaring
the security model of the web
with the capabilities app
developers want, right?
It needs to be safe
to click on links,
but app developers want
then access to everything.
And so I think that is the
hardest problem we always
deal with.
Things like these performance
issues, memory usage,
all this other rendering
performance, these
are places where
there's a linear path
to make progress
on, and I can see
the lines converging over time.
The inherent split between
every link is safe,
and I want access to send
SMSes from your phone, that
is the hardest
problem we deal with.
JAKE: So you mentioned,
having a meta
tag to say that something
is web app installable.
Is that-- because I'm aware of
the tags to say it's capable.
It can be added
to the home screen
and maybe appear without
a URL bar and things.
Apple's got one that will
actually sort of show an advert
for like a native app
equivalent over the top.
Do we advertise
the fact that this
can be installed to home
screen, and you'll get something
like a different experience?
ARNAUD WEBER: So it's
really-- we advertise the fact
that this web page can be added
to your home screen as a user,
and then we can get back to that
web app from the home screen.
JAKE: In terms of the--
because one of the things
I called it out and in my talk,
having the sort of slammed door
when you visit a website
that says, yeah, no.
We've got the information,
but it's an extra click away,
just because we want to tell
you about our app again.
Is Apple going to have a
decent solution to that?
They've got this
banner across the top.
Is that something--
are we looking
at implementing that
or something similar?
LINUS UPSON: Yeah,
I mean, we're all
tremendously frustrated by that.
You're in a browser.
I have no desire
to install the app.
I just use this
thing once, and I
have to go through this
interstitial of like, hey,
install my app.
We want to make that
go away, and we're
looking at a bunch
of different ways,
both technological
as well as social
and various economic
incentives and stuff
like that, so that people don't
put those barriers in front
of users, and they do the
right thing for users.
DARIN FISHER: Often
those interstitials even
break deep linking.
It's very, very frustrating.
JAKE: All right,
so I think we're
going to move on to
our last question.
So why have-- so we're not
adding any new CSS prefixes,
right?
That's Blink.
We're not going to add
the new CSS prefixes?
DARIN FISHER: No more.
No Blink prefix.
JAKE: There's not one there.
But we've got some
APIs that still have.
I mean, and one of the
ones is like, you've
got CSS transforms
and animations,
and they've left
behind a WebKit prefix.
And IE and Firefox have
shipped it unprefixed.
DARIN FISHER: Oh, right, yeah.
So there's a bug on this, and
there's a lot of dependencies.
Our goal, really, is to unprefix
these particular set of WebKit
prefix CSS properties once
they're up to the standards.
Basically, we don't want
to take away the prefix
until we are shipping the thing
that is compatible with what
these other browsers
are shipping.
So we have a set of
bugs to go through
before we could do that.
It's actually a
tremendous story.
Because if you look at
the Blink Dev thread here,
it's very much a
community effort.
I think one of the
guys from Intel
is very involved in doing some
of the work to make this happen
as well as folks from Google.
I think we're all excited
about getting to a point
where we can take
away WebKit prefixes.
And we might keep the WebKit
prefixed version around
for quite some time
because there's
a process for deprecation and
figuring out once nobody really
would care if we remove it.
That can take a while.
JAKE: Yeah, I think even Firefox
adopted some of them, right?
Because of people just
using that and not
the unprefixed version at all.
DARIN FISHER: Yeah.
I'm not sure to what
extent this has happened,
but certainly there was a
lot of discussion about,
oh my god, I guess
WebKit prefixed
CSS properties are
just a standard.
Some jumped out of
them, and people
tried to implement
them in other browsers.
And that just doesn't
seem like a good story,
and that's part of why Blink
does not have a Blink prefix.
JAKE: And with that,
that says out of time.
I hope you got your
questions answered.
And if not, do
bother us on Twitter.
We're here for the
rest of the day,
and we'll see what we can do.
Can I have a big round of
applause for our panelists?
[APPLAUSE]